hi there steve kaufman today i want to
talk about listening comprehension
questions
with particular reference to
a language learning
system that's being developed by the
canadian government called le morille
and i will get into that in a few
seconds i just thought i would
pass on for what it's worth uh my own
reaction to the coronavirus uh
pandemic that's developing around the
world i think we should be sharing
information on this
different perspectives i can just tell
you what i have done my perception is
that this is going to be with us for a
long time it's going to
be quite large in scale
uh people who are healthy even someone
in his mid 70s like me has a very low
chance of dying from it if peop there
are vulnerable people who are very much
at risk and therefore we should do
everything possible to limit the spread
to slow down the spread
washing hands i'm doing a lot of hand
washing i bought
wipes
so that when i go out i will have wipes
available to protect myself from
anything that i might be touching i
bought some
gloves that my wife and i will be using
if i go somewhere where i'm going to be
touching something that a lot of people
touch just to prevent me from getting it
not because i am likely to
you know
die from it but because if i get it i
can spread it to other people and the
more things that we can do to slow down
the spread the more we will protect
people who are actually very vulnerable
to this that's just as an aside and if
that's useful i got some you know my son
mark sent me something from a person who
has a lot of experience
in this kind of thing and those were
some of his recommendations
uh one other thing i did was buy some
zinc
tablets because apparently that boosts
your immune system so
anyway little small things that we can
do i don't think it's going to go away
in a hurry um hopefully we can delay the
spread of it and as i say help the more
vulnerable
people in our populations
and somehow we're going to have to learn
to live with it that's kind of my view
on this thing getting back then to
listening comprehension questions so
uh i got a notification from the
canadian government
that uh they were inviting me to bid on
a job to produce listening comprehension
questions
for a new
initiative
announced here at the end of may in 2019
so it's almost been a year
and the idea is to get the cbc radio
canada which is the
bilingual canadian or at least it's two
broadcasting systems one in french one
in english they are going to use their
programming and their podcasts as the
core of a language learning system for
french and english which will then be
available to canadians that's the way it
was announced
for canadians to learn the other uh
official language or if they're
immigrants to learn one or both of our
official languages
so the request for a proposal
i had to pay 27 to get into the
government you know website where you
bid on everything from road contracts so
gosh knows what
and so then i read this thing and
because i don't have any teaching
credentials and i haven't taught and
attended teaching school i'm not
qualified to participate nor is anyone
at links okay
but then i looked at it
and it got me to thinking so
what they want people to do
is to develop listening comprehension
questions you know first of all to help
the cbc hydro canada select out episodes
from amongst their various programs and
podcasts that they would they think that
we who were bid on this work think are
appropriate for different
levels of language competence now in
canada there is this system called the
12 language benchmarks and i think that
12 is is a unnecessarily
complicated system i i actually think
that beginner intermediate and advanced
is plenty uh if you go as far as the
european
framework you've now got six so beginner
a b intermediate a b advanced a b which
they call a1 a2
b1 b2 c1 c2 that's more than enough
however
the uh this system that the cbc canada
is developing which is called by the way
le morille in honor of a politician who
worked very hard on behalf of
francophones in ontario
uh
m-a-u-r-i-l mohil
by the way uh words and friends that end
in il are half the time the il is
pronounced as il
and half the time it's not pronounced
is your uh belly button for example
but anyway
leaving that aside he is mohil or he was
and the system is called
and so they said okay come in select
episodes that are relevant to different
levels within the canadian
benchmark system and then develop for
each episode a series of comprehension
questions
along with
two possible correct answers
so that the whole thing is based on
testing people's comprehension of these
episodes episodes that will be selected
by
whoever is behind the system
and then people will be tested on their
comprehension
my view is this is not going to be very
effective it's obvious the people behind
this are teachers teachers want to test
peop teachers want to put you in levels
and
it's possible that you can somehow
construe
these questions as a means of
establishing levels for people
it'll be arbitrary of course
because some people are better in
vocabulary and make grammar mistakes or
whatever
so you know to me that's pretty
arbitrary
and then also
to try to determine what is of interest
to whom i mean we understand things
better if we're interested in those
things so if we select what we want to
listen to ourselves we have a better
chance of understanding it or trying
harder to understand it um also in this
request for proposals they want people
who create these comprehension questions
to select out words and
phrases or structures that they think
are appropriate to different levels so
again we're going to be guiding the
learner at this level you should learn
these words and these structures at this
level you should learn these words and
these structures but of course in real
life it doesn't work that way we
gradually get used to a whole slew of
different words and structures and then
forget them and relearn them and
it's much more of a random fuzzy process
so i i don't i don't think that's going
to do much plus
i react
negatively
to being asked to remember
or to demonstrate that i remember
something in something that i've
listened to or read
i read it i listened to it it was in
another language i got it right i got it
wrong my business
as you know i'm very keen on the sort of
circling questions
where the objective is not to test the
learner's knowledge of what he or she
just listened to or read
the objective is to give some
concentrated and repeated exposure
to
certain
structures or certain phrases or certain
vocabulary items because obviously if
you have a circling question you say you
pull a statement out of
the podcast you say why when did he yes
or no
so that repeats the most of the words
and then you give an answer which
repeats most of the words so that it is
this
circling reading and listening to these
questions that helps with the
comprehension but testing people under
comprehension i'm not convinced helps
people with the comprehension
comprehension will gradually improve as
vocabulary improves so
i sent a letter to the people there
saying i think first of all
i would hope that you would simply
provide transcripts for all your
programming in english and french that's
the best thing you can do for language
learning in canada or elsewhere in so
far as english and french is concerned
harry potter has done much more for
english learners or for that matter
because many people use harry potter in
translation to learn other languages
that's a much bigger benefit to language
learning than any number of curricular
programs books etc that have been
developed for language learning so i ask
them please make transcripts of your
programming available
we would love to have that i would well
i'm not learning english in french but i
would encourage our learners to go there
and use this material and then to decide
what they're interested in and then save
the words and phrases that they're
interested in
and then i would recommend that they
hire people to go into these episodes on
a random basis and select out
you know certain statements in these
episodes and develop
circling questions around these episodes
which then should be available
for audio as download with transcripts
obviously
and so you just create more
comprehensible input and just let
learners
deal with the input deal with the
language
uh and gradually
improve their comprehension and if they
can choose things of interest
and if they see a process that is
enabling them to understand more and
more they will continue whereas if you
force them to try and remember things
and it's much more like tests back in
school i think a lot of people will be
turned off
the other thing was in the moril uh
terms of reference they say that this is
targeting people
in the sort of canadian benchmarks range
of level three to level eight so
assuming that six is the midpoint
so
my and it's sort of halfway between b1
and b2 on the european scale
you know i think that for people to be
able to
really make use of
podcasts films radio tv
programs
you need to be at least a b1
and maybe a midpoint maybe level six on
the canadian benchmarks
uh is where you need to be in order to
be able to use this material assuming
transcripts are there
um
and and so therefore they're eliminating
a whole bunch of people so i also
suggested that they should look at
the kinds of mini stories again these
sort of point of view
uh simpler stories
uh such as aj hogue has developed for
english let's just take his stories pay
them get aj hope stories lots of people
love them
uh and bring people who are level one
two three bring them up to that level
six so that they can start enjoyably
accessing these podcast radio tv
programs whatever it might be
and then continue to use the
circling questions technique in order to
allow people to enjoy the programs
rather than worrying too much about
proving that they understand something
slotting them into some level
uh
trying to tie content to certain levels
because they have the inevitable you
know for example the uh
content selected within the cbc in the
canada must reflect the diversity of
languages you know across the country so
it's very important to have you know for
the english we'll have some newfoundland
accent there and some uh whatever accent
like it doesn't matter the same with the
french accent most people can't hear the
difference they're mostly interested in
acquiring words and phrases
uh but so there's a fair amount of
politically correct nonsense in the uh
terms of reference as well
the government announced this they're
going to spend 16 million dollars they
announced it in may of 2019
it is now
march of 2020
following their terms of reference this
part of the process will be completed by
the end of 2020
so
i mean i think they'll manage to spend
their 16 million dollars
what they end up with and how effective
it will be and when they
launch this thing remains to be seen so
listening comprehension to my mind i go
back to
one of the people that i really enjoyed
listening to
uh when i was learning portuguese
was ruben alves who
passed away but he was a wonderful
brazilian educator and he said
nothing destroys the pleasure of reading
as much as and we can add in listening
nothing destroys the pleasure of reading
as much as being asked
what you understood to being asked to
analyze it break it down all of these
things
and i think the goal should be to
encourage people to read and listen in
the language they are learning and not
to make it more
cumbersome to do so or more frustrating
okay there you have it thank you
bye for now